so with a technique like this it reminds
me of you wants to talk about where it's
just page after page so seeing it as a
puzzle it's not crunchy it's not
physically changing the height of my
body by any means necessary
yeah it's I think the analogy of the
sinking is helping me because now I'm
not I'm trying not to focus on just
changing the height of my body but
instead figuring out how do I achieve
that sense of sync yeah I had covers of
raises
body but I keep attacking it from this
from this physics perspective you know
and when I do it like that I find I end
up using a lot more muster in the wrong
places and I should so at the very end
of strong throw to me equals this much
over
typing as opposed to Australian throws
Empress
so it's still opposed come tonight's
class felt like it's not this it's not
Davis not this is not there James you
know when I hear that it makes me
you know what we do here is very
different from what is done in most
places
and that always comes back to me for to
the reasons that you know the masses
can't be right by default I mean the
philosophers throughout the time that
pointed that out
in most schools since you guys probably
don't know much about this but there's a
very strong vibe that has everything to
do with modernity and the loss of our
the loss of our technologies of self
that help us because we have broken with
the past in the name of consumerism and
we've become scientistic and so we have
dropped the value of the mentor and a
mentoring system and that system has
been relegated to the shadows of our
society and so in the same goes for the
martial arts and the martial arts it is
a very
commonly held idea that teacher and acts
as a mentor
and that comes with any kind of
authority or
[Music]
demonstrates any kind of hierarchy
practical or otherwise is bad so most
people have this hesitation and this
problem with a mentor without ever
asking if I did want to have a mentor
could I because you'll find when you ask
that question that you you can't
you can you won't have the humility you
won't have the discipline you won't have
the commitment if you just don't and
your
your modern sensibility is actually a
modern incapacity and that becomes a
problem when I need to learn something
that is beyond words which is what
mentors did because almost every art
that you would ever study from violin to
dance to leather working is going to be
beyond words and ancient civilizations
didn't have a problem with that because
they didn't have this logo centricity
that we have and they didn't have this
dying need to sell how much money you
can make was not figuring into the
equation and I think when people train
now because they have this disdain for a
mentor and because there's an
underlining capacity for a mentor the
art has to be reduced to things you can
put into words so it's all angles and
technique exactly what I told you not to
do today don't do the technique you need
to find this other power source and you
do find it by not just not that exactly
like in those Buddhist sutras
why do they list it's neither this nor
that
it's neither this nor that right it's
not right nor left it's not above nor
below it's not inside nor outside it's
not on this mountain or on that mountain
it's not what this body saw for that
person because it's beyond those things
and by beyond means mostly you can't
learn it you cannot be transmitted by
those things and what modern martial
arts has done is just go without knowing
it enough generations have passed well
you don't have within you the capacity
to be mentored so I don't have to mentor
and I don't have anything to transmit in
the head
I will give you angles
I will give you architectures and so you
can learn these things on the internet
or on video or DVD I mean why do we have
that why is that so prevalent now you
can get a black belt you can train
online now as a historian that makes
sense
yeah you you lost the essence and you've
reduced it to these materialistic things
and so it's marketable and so you don't
need the teacher you just need the
techniques
even with the knot this knot that is to
feel it to feel the power was you can
you can feel you're like holy cow when
my teacher is you see the technique that
was that was always what stuck out to me
how in the world is there's so much
power you're not that much stronger than
me if you were so you can feel that and
then you can feel the other things that
happen like I mentioned the connection
all of a sudden my uke it knows exactly
where to go how do I explain that in a
text because when I say it it sounds
total but when you see it you
see the effect it's not anymore
you just can't explain it I was thinking
the other day of magnetic forces
everyone accepts magnetic forces have
you ever seen them is there a machine
that will show them you could do it do a
search on the internet and they go how
to view magnetic forces all you're
seeing is the effect but I can't see the
force itself but it's there everyone
knows it's there so the same thing I
don't know why I don't know why they
will find the right place to go without
knowing it I go back to the poetics on I
called employed X most teachers don't
call employed X I'm just you know I am a
modern person I understand science and
so I can tell that's a poetic term so
when they say like you're sticking to me
in the noggin that Luke is
sticking to you not you sticking to them
we've done experiments with the friction
and I'm trying to explain it to you but
even then I told you that's not really
it if you remember that day that's not
really what's going on here so that
they'll talk about a sticking that
happens in the guy that we lost viewed
his explanation was because he has to
keep his balance sometimes not all the
time that's not what's going on I don't
know what's going on my scientific
theorizing is more that our
understanding of gravity is too shallow
to make sense of what's actually
happening
not he's he doesn't want to fall so he's
gonna stay on there I don't that's not
it I don't think but because like I told
you I'm not academics so I don't need to
know that I just need to do it it works
so I do it but how do I even know that
exists if all I am studying is
architecture angles levers fulcrums this
is very dis this used to be a very basic
beginner understanding of an art like
Aikido but today is the apex for many
people and I think it's related to
modernity needs incapacity to be
mentored and like I said it's not that
mentoring does not exist it does it's
just hidden
those people that become masters that
whatever art yes they have a mentor and
they're having surreal abstract
discussions just like we do where
they're like you're playing the notes
but I don't feel it like what does that
mean then the teachers listening and the
student is able to stumble upon it and
then the teacher buzz yes that I feel it
the student doesn't know what okay it's
something in here you did it's kind of
like you're getting more and then you
keep looking and around in that area you
get it it makes sense to me that there
are other ways of learning than this
logo centric model and it makes sense
that we have a longer history
pre-enlightenment and we seem to learn a
great many things just fine before we
became logo centuries
the school systems that we have now
which has come to influence a lot of our
transmission systems is really based in
you know the industrial era I need two
things I need workers and I need
consumers
it's not really geared towards artistry
mastery
and this is what a culture does it comes
up with its economic needs workers
consumers and then it piles on to it
symbolic markets right and now you're
the best worker consumer because you
went to Harvard
you're still a worker consumer do you
guys understand now everyone tries to be
the best worker consumer they can be so
you go to your desk and you line up like
you are in a factory you go from place
to place like a factory like you're the
thing itself and to sit at the feet of
an artist and to listen and to believe
hey maybe there's more to life than
working and consuming it's just it's
people are terrified of it nowadays
but if you keep yourself afraid of it
you will not know what is beyond words
and then you will come to say there is
nothing beyond words that's when you've
lost that's when you've lost and I don't
know how anyone can really say that we
do all kinds of things that are beyond
words all kinds of things and and
usually they're the best things they're
the best things from from sex to love to
music to dance to right you you you
don't reflect back on your like like
when I reflected on the cherry blossoms
it's a feeling do you think I described
it accurately now you have to go you
have to go yourself you have to go see
it you I told you you wouldn't believe
it I told you I went not knowing I had
no idea I've heard people talk about the
Grand Canyon that way too they get to
the edge like nobody says anything just
a silence overwhelms them why if I tell
you the dimensions of the Grand Canyon
do you start going now we don't write
because it's beyond words so much of
life is like that and this art is like
that
there are many things as I said that I
did not get from my teachers when they
were alive because you just you run out
of time not this not that not just not
that not that cold cold cold hot cold
cool cool it's like that and then
they're gone but you it's in you do you
see and then you come back to it and I
can't tell you how many times I
and none of that had to do with somebody
going the angle is a 45-degree angle and
no no so when I look back at how what I
was learning and you've identified the
process my advice to you then would be
okay
stick to the feeling why should that be
a lesser form of inquiry I was watching
a show and the character is you know a
radicalized person and hurt the head of
her organization is talking to her and
wants her to say she won't continue this
radical behavior so if she's going are
you going to stop that radical behavior
and come to the media and she's like yes
so the words are yes but the meaning
that feeling is now and we communicate
like that all the time you could do that
go home go home to the to your
significant other try to do that do that
and see how far that gets you next time
do you love me of course I do
so I don't get why we because so III
don't believe that there's any validity
to the idea that my art must be reduced
to logo centric aspects and there's only
danger in a mentor because we live like
this all the time I think what it is is
this hiding of this incapacity what if
you wrote me the other day and said what
do I need most to improve my answer is a
trick commitment more commitment he is
what do you mean this is an answer same
answer for everyone isn't it more
commitment more commitment is more time
training more sacrifice right it's
everything
and it seems like it's an easy answer
until you are tasked with commitment
it's hard commitment is hard
and I think it's become very difficult
for us moderns very difficult and I
think the martial arts have suffered for
it
I think about the success lately of
Brazilian Jujitsu but I look at it the
other way because I've seen it happen
for so many decades if the popularity
doesn't knot does not mean that the
widespread successful dissemination of
the art it means the corruption of Lord
because the masses will come with their
lack of commitment I've never seen an
art degenerate so quickly it's happened
every every art
so I think this difficulty with
commitment it's very relevant and made
more so by the fact and I truly believe
this that the finding of this thing that
is neither this nor that is related
structurally to self displacement and
self displacement is necessary for
commitment
and I also think that what is neither
this nor that to embody that in a human
versus human violence that kind of
intense toxic situation requires even it
is even a greater challenge to the skill
of self displacement which means if you
can hold it in an idealized form you may
not be able to hold it when someone's
actually trying to kill you or where the
north quake has taken half your family
or what have you when the situation is
very intense so even though I made it
sound like it's the kind of historical
evolutionary thing this this disdain for
Mentors
this logo centric understanding of the
art the degeneration of the art I
actually believe that it is really more
subtle and more powerful in how we are
affected by it because it is
structurally the same thing the skill or
the incapacity for self displacement is
a sign of our times is a sign of our
unwellness is a sign of our disappearing
mentorships is a sign of our artistic
reductions is a sign of our inability to
find what is beyond words it all goes
together
I mean I asked you already to go with
what you felt and to do that you have to
actually feel and try to try to feel
anything without self displacement
we talked last week about feeling the
stones of the shower floor and the water
and all that self dysplasia you got get
out of the way
you're not in the way you're in the way
because you're like I gotta get to work
I could you're in the way so I think in
trying to feel you're actually trying to
regain your skill in self displacement
and so the art isn't really about the
architecture or even the power it's
about that skill in self displacement
this is what makes butoh a way it's not
just tidy or exercise